so for the moon or mars the most logical
thing to grow plants in is of course the
regulator you want to be able to have
grow your own food i mean if there's an
alien civilization they may be price
gougers you know
you want to protect against inflation
well how are you gonna
[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and i
got with me as a co-host paul mercurio
paul dude howdy good to see you my man a
bit too long oh yeah i know i know yeah
get together for lunch again yeah we'll
do it we'll do it with our buddy stand
up comedian and i just love the fact
that uh every time i'm on colbert you're
there warming up the crowd before
anything else happens so that's why
they're laughing and they're all always
in a good mood so
or if they're not it's my fault
i forgot i could blame you as well
why were they so excited but not
laughing enough why weren't they
laughing why were they
like oh my god so today's subject is
something i've been it's been
eating away at me because i've been
thinking about it ever since i've been
thinking about it all right and it's
like can you grow plants
on other planets
right i mean we think of putting seeds
in the ground and then it grows and all
you need is a little bit of water and a
little bit of sunlight and nobody's
thinking about what role the soil is
playing i mean no i mean regular people
aren't thinking this of course uh
experts think about it all the time and
so there's a word they use for the
the quote soils of the moon it's called
the regolith right it's a geology term
and we'll learn more about that in a
minute so so this whole show is going to
be if we're going to go to another
planet
either our moon or mars or wherever and
we're going to feed ourselves without
having
you know supply chains uh keep us alive
then then like
what do you do and how do you do it and
i have no such expertise in this so we
combed the world and we found two people
who
who this is what they do uh let me first
introduce annalisa paul and alisa
welcome to start talk
thank you so happy to be here excellent
so you're the director at the
interdisciplinary center for
biotechnology
and a and researcher at the university
of florida okay and a research professor
at horticultural studies right art
sciences yep
horticultural sciences very good and so
you think about you're playing you're
you've had a green thumb from early on
is this what we're telling us
yeah yeah yeah kind of but i also would
describe myself as you know simple
country molecular biologist there you go
i love it i'm a country molecular
biologist we need more of those yes
exactly just got a quick question how
good are your tomato plants at home are
they good or are they
that's the litmus test because if
you got crappy tomatoes we we're finding
another guest we've done some research
and we have photos that are
that's right but my arabidopsis crap
craft is um pretty good
all right
we'll get top people we're looking into
that and we've got uh with us also one
of your collaborators in this effort uh
robert furl professor and vp of research
in horticulture is that am i saying that
right robert
i'm i'm vice president for research at
the university of florida there it goes
thank you and you're with a special you
have to have academic specialty of
horticulture but if you're a vp of
research you're overseeing all the
research in the science there correct
well i have a role in enabling the
research overall at the university of
florida that is so politely tactfully
said
you don't want to make any enemies just
by how i describe what you do
very good and you um
i have here your uh interests are
environmental regulation of gene
activity in plants
so i love this combination of expertise
because it's not just let's find a seed
on earth and then grow it somewhere else
you might have to do some serious gene
editing
to make that happen so
i i just i'm i'm ready to sort of jump
into this and so could could could one
of you just start us off
and tell me
um
do we have experience trying to grow
things
on moon soil did the apollo astronauts i
know they brought back rocks but did
they bring back bags of soil too
yeah so
you're turning in on one of the really
interesting parts of sort of apollo
history that drew us into this business
we're
we're space biologists we're very used
to sending experiments to the
international space station and
understanding the role of gravity
in terrestrial biology and in fact
trying to think about how we would feed
in
astronauts as they're
as they're traveling between planetary
bodies um
in our solar system
but it turns out that this whole notion
of whether plants whether biology
interacts with lunar samples is one of a
pretty deep historical note
the apollo astronauts to answer your
question they sure did bring back lunar
dirt they brought back all kinds of
rocks they brought back all kinds of
samples of
the dust and the dirt that was in and
around their sampling sites richard so
paul you notice he can't call it soil
notice that yes
and all i'm thinking about dirt is like
somebody had it on their boots when they
walked into the laboratory and you just
started screaming hello
that's why we have a mat at the door
you're an astronaut you can't figure
that out
until biology touches it it really can't
be called soil all right all right so we
can have we have because of our work we
actually have lunar dirt lunar soil in
our laboratory now because it's been in
contact with biology
so to round out your question about dirt
yep
apollo astronauts did bring soil did
bring dirt back from
the moon they kept it they nasa they the
lunar sample curators in the lunar
sample community kept it under tight
wraps at johnson space center
for the purposes of of studying
lunar geology primarily but it's one of
the great untold stories unremembered
stories under appreciated stories of the
apollo era is the role that biology
played including plant biology
in determining that the samples that
came back from the moon
were not dangerous
did not have lunar
pathogens
okay so let me ask you analisa if if we
know in advance that it's not earth soil
and whatever it is if
by the way i'm glad somebody uh your
your your your professional brethren
from a previous generation
did decide that there was no bug that
was brought back
from the moon uh you may remember the
novel the andromeda strain which came
out right around that time which was a
bug from space that totally wreaked
havoc and of course
i think that was
michael crichton's first novel before he
wrote jurassic park and a whole lot of
other things so he had some good sort of
bio chops to to give us
fun thrillers but but anna-lysa if we
already know there's nothing
living or we suspected and confirmed
nothing living in the soil then
isn't the challenge
to grow
plants in something that doesn't have
living organisms and who cares if it's
regalith or anything else
well so there's a lot of there's two two
layers of stuff there first of all they
never grew plants in it even back in the
apollo days all they ever did was a
scientist biologist called charles
walkenshaw just sort of rubbed the
surfaces of the leaves it'll sprinkle
down the surface just to see if there
are anything pathetic or anything but
nobody ever correctly grew it in the
dirt in the in the regolith to see if it
would actually support plant growth and
development so we had no idea whether
there wouldn't be something
toxic to plants or something too
reactive to plants that would able to
support it so
if you if you're going to go someplace
else you have to be able to have plants
as part of the equation to support
long-term goals you have to have plans
to recycle your air remove water in
addition to providing food and the best
way to do that is if you can use in-situ
resources something that's already there
so you have to carry it with you
so for the moon or mars the most logical
thing to grow plants in is of course the
regulator yeah and you and you want to
be able to you want to be able to have
grow your own food i mean if there's an
alien civilization they may be price
gougers you know
you want to protect against inflation
well how are you gonna you can't haggle
with an alien
you're 2 000 years away from home you
don't have any leverage so whatever
they're going to charge you so you want
to have it but just to be clear paul the
moon is one third of a light second yeah
this is where you don't have to be so
smart and correct me just go along with
it
one and a half light seconds sorry i got
the wrong number there um no but but if
so i hadn't considered that of course
it's not whether they're microbes that
could help it but whether there's
something that would actively destroy it
that would be that would be bad too
right very good okay right and nasa
correct me if i'm wrong does i remember
this 20 years ago do they still have
a
a a branch of themselves called
that specializes in in-situ resource
utilization isru yep
okay absolutely and why did it um it was
50 years right with uh
that before
you actively started trying to grow
things and in the regular one
why was there such a long period of time
or if i'm off on that a little bit it
was a long period of time before you
started trying to grow things
in the soil why
why was that i mean neil armstrong had
to be upset because he must have been
calling like every other week going hey
you know all that dirt i brought back
you guys using it for anything
because i
took up a lot of space for tang on the
ship and i uh but i was willing
is there a reason that you guys
it took a while to start to use some of
that
well there there are several reasons and
and many of them are
i think tied up with the simple fact
that
until
the collective we decided to go back to
the moon with the artemis program those
lunar soil samples that were at johnson
space center kept under nitrogen and
controlled conditions were the only ones
we were going to have
and so they were very very careful nasa
was very very careful with
how much and what kinds of samples they
put out to the to the community to study
and by and large the questions that
needed to be answered was
things associated with the age of the
moon and the geology of the moon
biology going to the moon
interacting with the moon was just down
the road it's important it's right down
the road yeah yeah so anna-lysa tell me
about the florida space
plants lab
like what do you guys do
well so it's a directed by rob and
myself and we do mostly what you think
of as orbital signs
so we do a lot of
plants to the space station and ask the
very simple question is how do plants
respond at the molecular level to the
novel environment of space flight so we
look at patterns of gene expression
things what molecular tools plants are
pulling out of their toolbox but we also
do what we call sort of exploration
science and suborbital science so we can
test
what kind of uh things we can learn
about plants in any of these kind of
environments that we may face ourselves
with in the future right so the
environment just to be be clear um rob
when i think of the space environment of
course as an astrophysicist you're in
zero g but there's also
uh
high energy flux of particles from the
sun that could affect dna i suppose i
know at low earth orbit we're a little
bit insulated from that but um in terms
of quote space environment it seems to
me it's it's more than just a zero g
proposition correct
oh absolutely and
much like the previous question about
lunar soil samples most of our space
biology research
for the last 20 years has been in low
earth orbit the opportunities to study
biology beyond the van allen belts
biology on the moon or biology in deep
space
basically didn't exist it wasn't an
option and so
to
drive back to the question many many of
our scientific questions are about
what happens in microgravity in the
absence of unit gravity here on earth
that's something that's been a driving
evolutionary presence for all of biology
forever
but again going back to the moon now
opens up
sort of
the intellectual floodgates and we do
have to come to grips with the question
what happens to biology
when it's not protected by a magnetic
field so absolutely solar flux is an
important thing are there layers here in
other words once you establish you can
grow something in the regolith like so
you have to factor in cosmic rays solar
winds and and how you can
in the substrates and
how do you
have you started to look at i guess what
neil was referring to as the environment
and the effects on the regolith if
you're going to do this
going forward or is that farther down
the road to try to figure some of that
out
so there's a couple layers of questions
there as well
wow i'm pretty sure i mean tons of
layers
like an onion
so
but if you think about anything i love
that the horticulturist says it's layers
like you got food references to
everything here
i was thinking more of shrek actually
but yeah okay
but
but you have you're going to be growing
in a habitat so you're not going to
worry so much about things like
the solar wind
because you're going to be as protected
the plants will be as protected as the
humans inside a habitat however the
solar wind does affect the regolith
itself
from before you've collected it and
that's one of the things that we found
in the work that rob and i did is that
the older regular stuff that's been
exposed to the solar went longer is
actually more
hostile to plant growth than the quote
younger we're talking a billion years
younger regulate of other sites
interesting and of course the solar wind
just embeds in the surface of the moon
and it just stays there it doesn't erode
it doesn't wash away with the streams
so you've got quite the record there and
just to make sure because rob mentioned
the van allen bell i want to make sure
we're all on the same page here the
um i hadn't heard reference to the van
allen belt in decades so thanks for
bringing that up again um so the the
earth has these sort of magnetic zones
that can actually trap particles and
prevent them from coming lower and
funnel them to the poles and give us the
aurora borealis this sort of thing and
so if you were orbiting within that
you're basically protected but once you
go beyond that you don't have these
repositories these protective layers and
zones
protective because it otherwise would be
hostile to life as we know it so yeah
thanks for that bit of memory lane there
well i got to tell you this is going to
be great for me because i you know
trying to grow something in harsh
conditions if
i'm going to give you an ex my sister i
if you i me it's similar to me i can't
grow a philodendron i guess i keep
freaking watering it and um my watering
process is terrible so if you can help
me with the harsh conditions that i put
my plants under i think we'd be in paul
machado proof plants that's what they're
they're going to put that ahead of the
space plants paul okay please
please i feel like i'm a common man and
they we all have the same problem
someone could just remind me to put some
uh water on the plants but um
yeah we're gonna take a break and when
we come back we'll get uh deeper into
what kinds of seeds are being used and
what kind of modifications to them are
necessary and what kind of food is
produced because i hope it's going to be
something other than kale okay
i ain't going into space all right so i
got nothing against kale
but if you blanch it it's fine no it's
not no it's always bad so uh we'll we'll
be right back we're talking about
growing food in space on star talk
we're back star talk we're talking about
growing plants not only in space but in
destinations in space such as the moon
and perhaps mars and beyond
and you can't just plant the seeds you
got it you need a little more than that
and i've got with me two experts two
two folks who are colleagues at the
university of florida who are
horticulturists with special interest in
in
biotechnology and and
show not quite astral biology
that would be life forms that develop
somewhere else we're talking about
developing earth life elsewhere and both
of them are totally into this published
papers together on it and that's why we
got them both here for this program and
i got with me of course paul mercurio
had to help me out and so let me just
ask you guys what
um what studies have you done with what
seeds and why did you choose those seeds
instead of others and what's the what's
the thinking behind your experiments all
right that that's an easy one so we
mostly work with the model organism for
plants it's called arabidopsis
phthaliana we just call it a rhapdoxis
for short and it's it's a tiny plant the
genome has been completely sequenced
it's been used all over the world for
all manner of types of experiments and
so
why we chose it for growing in lunar
regolith is both its size it can grow
just a teeny tiny thing and grow in a
quarter teaspoon of material it's also
completely sequenced there's a lot of
reference material on growing it in
other types of harsh environments and
stress responses and so we have a huge
compendium of information that backs up
all the stuff that we will find about
drawing it in regular as well as
grounded in space a number of times over
the years you know at least i'd never
thought about it of course you guys
would want to do the same thing that
sort of people who use laboratory
animals do right i've looked it's
completely freaked me out opening up a
catalog of mice
you can you can you can short order mice
that are identical to
thousands of other mice that are
distributed around the world so that you
when you compare your research results
the full genome is identical so that you
can remove the variables and only look
like you can remove things that you
don't want to vary and look at the
things that you do and that's what
you're doing with this seed isn't that
correct yep exactly
that is i'd love it i love it now did
you guys create this oh it's sequenced
but did anybody genetically
create it or engineer it we just found
one that everybody just agreed would be
good for this purpose
yeah for this particular experiment we
used uh one of the what is called a
standard strain
one that is um as analysis described
very well characterized by thousands of
laboratories on earth for all kinds
of environmental studies and
developmental studies so the real
question is does it contract cancer like
all species of mice do
really i've been working out i've been
exercising i got cancer come on
right every mouse ever studied in the
lab gets cancer can i say this the
arabidopsis sounds
actually it sounds like uh on a as on
the salad or mint uh appetizer menu of
it you'd find it like in a three-star
michelin you know restaurant it sounds
delicious but it's you know it's a
veggie can you guys work on a plant that
tastes like pizza maybe you know
something a little more fun or
krispy kreme doughnuts that's top secret
that's a top secret project
they've got a glazed doughnut a powdered
doughnut so is this an edible plant is
it an edible plant i mean edible is it
i'm following up on paul's comment is
this a seed and plant that we would
consider eating or is it you just got to
get any kind of plant working at all
first
a little bit of both so
could you eat it yes have we eaten it oh
sure is it really tasty
yeah you know it's just tastes like a
green plant it's uh
it tastes like chicken
only the ones that we've engineered with
chicken flavor no there you go all right
now you're talking i want to go to space
right now i want to go
okay so you have to this is this is you
have to crawl before you walk and walk
before you run right you want to get any
kind of you want to get plants to do
this at all and that becomes the the
starting point is that fair yeah yeah
that's why we call it a model plant
okay and does it have any special
dare i call them talents where it needs
fewer
nutrients relative to other plants i
mean does it do better under stress
conditions you know it's i'm just
wondering
uh because you you'd want to start
broadening how much you stress the
system the plant right so that you can
enclose as much of what goes on in space
as possible
well i'd say the only talent that this
that this arabidopsis has is that it's a
member of the mustard family and
the mustard family is really
plastic and resilient in all sorts of
environments i mean think about all the
different
vegetables that you eat everything from
broccoli to paul's favorite kale and uh
turnips all these things are all in the
same family um but just to be clear uh
you use the word plastic oh
amanda is invaluable thank you thank you
you just ruined every hot dog for me
from now on by the way you ruined
everything you ruined my baseball games
my fourth of july cookout now you're
using the word plastic
in its original definition which gave it
the name to the petroleum byproduct that
that it's called plastic right the word
plastic well said predates plastic
and you're using it in the original term
okay so that's a good fact about the
plant and there but there are stre and
there's but there are stresses within
the diff the different soil samples you
use right some have heavy metal and salt
uh some are more sensitive to drought
right so
um so you found
different results based on the three
different apollo missions the soil that
you brought back right and that the
older the soil
the less fruitful it was right so it
doesn't matter what plant you're putting
in it right you you've got to you've got
to first somehow
control that soil in some way and
eliminate some of those stresses within
the soil regardless of the plant is that
right yeah so
you're hitting on what may well be one
of the more fundamental things that that
we discovered as part of this project
yeah well then i think i'm done if i did
yeah oh yeah just stop there paul
because i think yeah i'm gonna go have
i'm gonna have a hot dog with ketchup
and uh
yeah
very clearly what what what we found
with these plants yeah is
that they in some ways act as if they
are stressed
but
one of the one of the key things in
terms of interpreting this and i think
you know this will appeal to you is that
this is an experience beyond the
evolutionary experience of these
particular organisms and
so paul to interpret our results
directly um as equivalent to a
terrestrial response that we know about
might be right it might be only partly
right because
as anna-lysa mentioned they're reaching
into their metabolic toolbox to deal
with what they found
and what they found is quite literally
brand new it's out of their world so so
we have a job ahead of us to help
the world interpret
what the plants are telling us um and it
could be yes that they have they have to
deal with heavy metals and other things
that are different among different soils
on the moon yes
it could be there are other general
things that they're dealing with simply
because
they're in
a strange new environment
does it matter what area of the moon the
regolith comes from does it do you get a
different
soil like i mean look it's pretty
obvious that
uh
neil armstrong got a got bump steered
into lousy territory when he was drugged
when he was walking around the moon oh
just a little known fact all right they
the astronauts landed in the maria which
is very flat areas but i told mario
which is latin for seas because at one
point people thought that the
wide dark areas were
were because they were flat that they
were bodies of water and
before anyone really knew any physics or
chemistry but the reason why they landed
there is because it was flat and they
didn't want the lunar module to try to
land on something that would end up
tipping it over on some uh unfavorable
terrain
for a horizontal landing so that was it
was a safety region
initially
if the if the soil that that armstrong
brought back on 11 had been used earlier
i guess it just aged it's not like wine
it goes the opposite it doesn't age well
right so if it had been fitted where is
seven well wait wait wait wait paul she
just said this stuff has been there a
billion years so what's 60 years gonna
do for anybody that wait what are you
saying yeah i i you know
it seems well there's a difference
between this dirt from 17 and the dirt
from 11 right right in terms of its
efficacy so there must be something okay
what is the difference so what is the
difference okay so so the difference is
is that the apollo 11 materials were
exposed to the solar wind for and i'm
not going to get the number exact but
say a billion years longer than the
samples in apollo 12 the apollo 12
landing site right so in that billion
years as neil said earlier you don't
have anything to weather it per se you
just keep accumulating the deposits from
the solar wind the heavy metals the
the nanophase iron the different things
that make it also sharper and and
more reactive surfaces and things and so
it just gets more and more
to a plant hostile
and so is there a difference among the
sites absolutely is it something we can
mitigate yeah probably
so
that's interesting just in case people
didn't know
uh you know we take this phrase heavy
metal for granted but there are light
metals i don't know if anyone has ever
thought about what the light metals are
such metals exist aluminum is a light
metal and it is light enough to have the
density of rock
and we think of rocks as heavy but
aluminum having the density of rock
means you'll find aluminum at least on
earth aluminum and rock in the same
places because they settled out in the
original molten earth uh having the same
density and so aluminum is like one of
the most abundant elements in earth's
crust so aluminum titanium um sodium are
all light metals that's all and there's
never a light metal band right
it's called barry manilow
um why did why did volcanic ash
some of these plants did a lot better in
volcanic ash right well i like that
right the moon has a fascinating
volcanic history and we know on earth
volcanic regions not initially because
it kills everything but then it becomes
very fertile uh uh soil so
so
if we in the future might we target sort
of volcanic planes which which many of
these maria are but uh is there anything
we can learn from volcanic fertile
places on earth and and apply that to
these other planets
so paul were you also asking perhaps
about the controls that we used volcanic
materials that we used as a control
so we use this uh material jsc 1a which
is a lunar simulant that yes it's a type
of volcanic ash it's ground-up basaltic
material that's as similar as to the
lunar materials that that from kids
stanford johnson space center i bet that
is correct yeah okay yeah so it's their
own it's their own sort of off-the-shelf
uh starter kit i guess right there
okay it's a brand exactly good branding
but i guess what i'm asking is the there
are places on the moon that are less
volcanic than others
and given that i've tasted many a wine
from volcanic soils here on earth and
the viticulture is extolled for its
virtues
um okay can we say that there's
in the future we might target volcanic
regions versus others
i think that would be one in growing
food and growing wine
on the moon would be one set of factors
yes they would choose the landing site
i suspect that it wouldn't be the major
driver for where we go well i think you
need to change your priorities then
i think it should all be about the wine
the wine on the moon right
the news already made of cheese right so
the right cheese is and legalize
marijuana i mean if that when that kicks
in
i'm there
[Music]
so the regolith didn't do as well as a
volcanic ash that's the bottom line but
it did get a participation trophy i just
yeah
so it kind of did well but but can you
take properties from the volcanic ash
and factor it into the regolith maybe
you can maybe you can't right
sure so the uh the terrestrial volcanic
ash uh is and again both the the the
lunar materials and the the simulant are
both essentially ground-up basalts and
so they have the fundamental
characteristics of each other but the
whereas the the material from earth is
more rounded it's it's less reactive it
has less surface areas less sharp um you
did use that word sharp i i hadn't fully
appreciated that the texture of
something matters greatly in terms of
the interaction of
it and its surroundings right right i
mean think of the difference between a
sea glass and something you dropped on
your kitchen tile the same day
right
right
yeah you can walk on sea glass right
it's basically smooth pebbles right
right so
well you could walk on your freshly
broken glass but you'll cut yourself
that's big exactly
let me ask a question that will surely
blend into our third segment
there's not enough
talked about i mean in in people who
think about this know about it but in
the public
the fact that
you know an ant can walk straight to a
wall and then just walk up the wall
right and we can't do that
and an ant could get
trapped in a small bubble of water
and
because of the surface tension of the
water and all i'm saying is that for
small things gravity as we experience it
becomes less and less and less important
to their lives
and so
you have plants growing in 0g
on the international space station
and you study its molecular
uh changes
properties
of genetic code
why should zero g have any effect on it
at all when it's at the molecular level
and why do molecules give a rat's ass
about gravity
that's a great question
and and it's really not whether the
molecule cares it's whether the organism
cares right oh the fuller organism oh
okay yeah yeah all right so do plants
care whether there's gravity or not
that's a big question well they do grow
up instead of down so maybe
maybe so not mine not mine
you know
yours just don't grow that's just you
know
it's really all about cues right it's
all about directional cues and so on
earth plants
have evolved to use gravity
so the roots grow down the sheets grow
up but wait how do you wait wait how do
you know the the the shoots grow up
against gravity rather than towards
sunlight
they do both actually okay let's hold
that let's hold that we're going to take
a quick break and when it comes back
we're going to get into sort of the
molecular physics of these plants and
what forces of nature
do they care about most and what do they
just not care about at all on star talk
we're talking about growing plants in
space
not only in orbit but on planetary
bodies when we return
we're back star talk talking about
growing plants in space
in orbit
planetary bodies i got paul mercurio
with me paul how do we find you on
social media plus you got a podcast
don't you yeah it's uh called inside out
with paul mecurio you've been on it uh
your name is in the podcast my name is
in the podcast just only so i remember
who's it
cause i have a thing
yes so you can get it wherever the
millions and millions of podcasts are
sold as they say and uh and paul
mercurio that's where you get at ball
material okay
if you do m-e-r-c-y-o there's an
australian actor who has a really he
wears tight pants that's not me okay
so
we have with us of course uh annalisa
paul and
robert fernell both on the faculty at
the university of florida specializing
in horticulture with sides of interest
that
uh help us figure out how you're gonna
grow plants in space possibly to eat
them one day and how can we find you
guys uh how can the public find what you
you guys do well we have a a laboratory
website called uf space plants and if
you were to
just google that you you come up with us
i suppose nice so uf as university of
florida uh space and space plants i just
love that pairing of those two words it
just sounds great i love you we heard of
space aliens but space plants you know
by the way i have on good authority uh i
don't know if you knew this i i couldn't
imagine i could tell the two of you
something you didn't know in advance but
i bet this is one of them that e.t
e.t from the movie e.t was conceived as
a sentient
plant
hmm
cool that's why that's why et had that
glowing finger and you'd come near the
plants and the plants would rejuvenate
do you remember this from the movie yeah
yeah
yeah so et was a vegetable not an animal
just though i'd tell you that i knew you
you would dine and learn something like
that today
i like it
yeah
surprising the kid liked it if it was a
vegetable it was that's a strange
comment
usually kids don't like vegetables
these two great scientists uh the
aerodoptus which is you know the basis
for your research what is the best
vinaigrette to go with that have you
done that research yet and where are we
on that so that's a very important
question for the astronauts actually
johnson space center has a food lab
where they
they they combine flavors that have a
good enough shelf life for long-term
space missions
just a little avocado vinaigrette that's
just my suggestion
hit the sweetness will make all the
difference you got it there you go
so tell me tell me again about
how do you know that the plant is
reaching up against gravity rather than
reaching up towards sunlight because
wasn't it for a long while didn't we
think that plants turned towards the sun
because they wanted sunlight but in fact
sunlight was killing some chemical in
their
in their on the side of the of the
branch that it ended up curling towards
it and it was just a side effect
that the leaves face the sun isn't that
what isn't that what's actually going on
inside the plant this is precisely what
is going on so that's actually very well
said it's not that uh they're they're
but they are doing that they are
reaching towards the sun but they do
that by because they've evolved such
that when you have too much sun what it
does is it makes the other side of the
cell elongate more and so as it
elongates it causes it to curve the same
thing happens with
in
for gravity sensing the plants are
growing down
on earth but if you say if you take a
plant to to an environment that has no
gravity you lose the gravity cue and so
you still have to rely on light for that
cube yeah but if you haven't seen it
if you have a seed embedded in a blob of
soil and you're in zero g and then you
water it
however you do that because there's no
gravity but okay you get water in the
soil however you do it magically how
would how does the seed which know which
way to open and then pop out of your
blob of soil so we've done this
experiment essentially
we've done that it's that the blob
becomes auger on a plate it comes closed
in light we've done them in the dark the
plant has an inherent mechanism on how
to grow away from where it's planted
because if it didn't it would just grow
in this little tight blob and then it
would use up all the nutrients right
around it and it would die
and so it has an inherent mechanism to
elongate and make this sort of a coil
kind of uh growth pattern that takes it
away from its planet this the the roots
just coil away the shoots coil away in
the other direction and eventually you
get something that looks more or less
like a plant even when you grow them in
the dark but if you grow in the light
then plants without gravity use light as
a cue the plants roots grow away from
that light and the plant shoots grow
towards that light even without gravity
or at least away from which way the
shoot is going because if you're in the
soil won't see the light at all like
that's true right right so how about all
these people i see growing plants i get
is it called hydroponic growing plants
just in a pot of water uh why can't you
just do that in space well in fact you
you can one can and one of the
sort of major engineering thrusts of
plant growth in space is try to
understand how to manage water in zero
gravity
because
in the absence of gravity capillary
action takes over and you get blobs of
water attached to your roots and so you
can essentially drown your roots with
very little water
in space simply because gravity is not
pulling the water away
so there is there's a lot of
biology and water management that is on
earth dependent upon gravity especially
for hydroponics
or things related to that so
so yeah water management is a big deal
and would that be a way a non-soil way
to grow plants in space for life support
yeah absolutely
okay but they would have to still feed
the nutrients right
and sure they'd have to be nutrient-rich
water can't get distilled water right
and that's called miracle-gro neal
everybody
just between the four of us do you guys
cheat a little bit and throw a little
miracle grow in when you're doing these
experiments yeah
just to say
i look at rob
there you go absolutely
this is breaking news everybody we just
get there
so what about light and the you know the
light that these plants need and we'll
need i know there's going to be
controlled environments in space but
right i mean
have you experimented with different
types of lighting that these different
plants need dude have you never grown
marijuana you just get a grow light what
like what kind of question is that
i haven't but i know somebody else of
course you haven't recorded this meeting
no initially just in all fairness to
that question when i first thought about
the problem i said if you're going to
travel to the outer solar system the sun
gets dimmer and dimmer and dimmer and
dimmer so you can't rely on sunlight and
i was imagining you couldn't grow plants
but of course you can you just have some
other grow lamp right
well so paul again
potentially by pure mistake or random
error or landed on a very very
fundamental wait a minute wait a minute
are you the vice president of passive
aggressive compliments at the university
of florida
i got stopped by red i wrote stuff right
it
i asked a good question so i could
record this and tell my wife that i
asked a smart question anyway
so here's here's the real deal the the
question of how you would get lights to
your plants on another planetary surface
is a very fair one because you have to
trade off the cost of generating the
energy
for lighting up the leds against the
cost of building for example a light
collector
and a translucent tube to bring that
light to your growth surface which would
be a passive would be energy for you
yeah plus you've got to factor in use of
electricity for the disco ball every
saturday night when you're having your
disco party on them all of this all of
the about all of this has to be
attracted
but continue sir
no no
that's basically it the whole idea of
how you manage light
um as you transit around the solar
system um or whether you dig underground
and use nuclear power with your leds or
whether you pipe light in from the
surface these are all this is the stuff
of science fiction
but it's
becoming science fact in reality as we
think about what a habitat on the moon
might look like do we want natural
sunlight how do we collect it how do you
pipe it down into where you're going to
live whether you're a person or a plant
okay so here's the 900 question will all
future astronauts have to be vegetarians
or is there some way you're gonna also
uh sustain animal life out there
that would then be edible i guess
chickens or something i mean is there is
there a
a it's who's thinking about this
nasa's actually thinking a lot about
this um
the problem is is that the best
animal protein sources are not commonly
utilized in western cooking things like
mealworms
and insects in general i guess
exactly
exactly is there is there a way to
make sure that any of these astronauts
who are vegetarians have the gene taken
out of them where they lecture you about
how great being a vegetarian is
can you guys work on that please
i'll give you more of the questionnaires
yeah i'll give you more of my life
information and my brilliant lighting
questions but please we can all work on
that
brilliant liking
but otherwise there's uh you know what
you haven't talked about is fungus
right fungus i mean mushrooms are
are are occasionally described as being
meaty maybe that would be the compromise
between a pure vegetarian diet and one
that
um
would involve meat
because portobello mushrooms taste meaty
do that also uh helps with this concept
of what do you do with all the biomass
that you can't eat directly so you need
something to help break that down and so
you're right funguses could do that and
let's not forget about psychedelic
mushrooms i'm just putting it out there
okay just i'm just it's in case being in
space is not enough for you
[Laughter]
yeah this is all right but i really like
this is a trip but i'd really like to be
tripping right now
in the end we will be traveling whether
we wanted to by design or not we'll be
traveling with microbes
fungi and
probably intentionally with plants but
we will have a an ecosystem of some
sorts wherever it is we're living um so
back to your question about fungi
when would they be part of the ecosystem
that does
remove
um
that does do some
composting if you will in space as part
of the life support system yeah very
likely
and paul you can tell rob is vp because
once again he's he said it very
tactfully uh let me tell you what he
didn't say
is what he actually said right there is
fungus growing on our skin
and all over our bodies
that we're taking into space no matter
what okay now i have to take a shower
after this show
rob am i correct you left you didn't say
that but you know that's what you meant
you are of course absolutely correct
there's no way we are sterilizing our
skins and our innards when we're
traveling anywhere and i love rob
because he says really scary stuff that
it doesn't sound scary at all
you know that was kind of a good
question you dummy like that kind of
stuff i just love this i uh thank you
i'm going to have to have an extra
therapy session this week rob i
appreciate it here we go let me ask you
this real quick about apollo 11 the
regular from that versus 12 and 17 12
and 17
you it gave you better uh book plants if
you will or whatever so would that be
like to put in layman's turf so that
with the food generated by the apollo 11
regolith versus the 12 and 17 12 and 17
would be like
food sold at whole foods way above what
it should be costing and then the apollo
11 stuff would be sold at like costco is
that kind of how this would work
if there were a costco please don't
please don't answer yes to that
[Laughter]
that just took away from my light
question that like no no no yeah
but but in in all fairness one of the
real questions would be
does it taste differently if it's grown
in different
different soils
another good question actually that's
brilliant that's right because wine
picks up some of that flavor yeah
yeah
well but let me let me catapult this
cause i'm done with apollo in this
conversation let's let's go straight to
poop potatoes which were famously grown
on the surface of mars during the movie
the martian so first
question one how good is human feces as
a fertilizer relative to like cow
poop second
how realistic is that because by the way
professionally
uh in the in the storyline matt damon's
character was a botanist
so he's supposed to be all up in how
that's supposed to work
and so
uh can you comment on
the the the
efficacy of his actions in that film i'm
gonna i'm gonna start by saying first
off
there
there is almost never in the history of
movie making where the botanist is the
space hero so let's just celebrate that
by the way
what it is i got raked over the kohl's
and twitter i think i said something
like um it seems to me
it would be easier
for the engineer to know as much
engineering as he did to pick up some
botany on the side than for the botanist
to know all the engineering that he did
so and then the botanist just just
wrapped because you're right
because we have engineering heroes in
science
all the time i should have backed up and
given the botanist the day and the sun
so
just let us have our escapism for two
hours i i i did the same with the movie
arrival the movie arrival we want to
talk to aliens and they got a linguist
and a physicist it's like no
get a get a get a a cryptographer and an
astrobiologist and then her language
jumped all over me well yeah well you
should hear him go off on mary poppins
no one can fly with an umbrella
really let me see
i will concede
the we have a hero botanist okay so now
let's get back to the poop potatoes
all right so i'm gonna i'm gonna
jump in on this one first of all i am
happy to say neither rob nor i are
experts in poop so okay
that's a separate profession that's a
separate sub-profession of what you guys
do okay however i will say that the uh
the martian regolith as far as we know
from lander studies and stuff not as far
as we know but as far as you know like
scientists know it's full of things like
perchlorates for instance toxic stuff
plants hate it so do humans and if you
have perchlorate type soils here on
earth what do you do you mix it with
water and you mix it with organic
materials to help mitigate the toxicity
of that
so just saying now damon was close okay
so so he had the the the
the
uh hermetically sealed poop of everyone
and which meant whatever was anaerobic
was still happy still in there i presume
right and
because your lower gut is all anaerobic
right so but his poop wasn't
representative of poop in general
because it was all based on just eating
potatoes and and whatever that pill he
was grinding up so ha ha you can't you
know he didn't use his own poop he used
the poop in the trash left by his crew
of all the days they had spent there oh
don't you remember he cut open the
packet and he said so there were
okay so there is some
some
sci-fi authenticity to that absolutely
and we do we do have to answer the
question human poop yes is perfectly
good for fertilizer so why don't we all
just poop into our houseplants
i gotcha gotcha okay
no i'd done that experiment
not intentionally i was drunk but you
know what good things come from drinking
what can i tell you
hey speaking of martian neil when they
do the sequel who is going to play who
are we going to cast to play hanna lisa
and who is going to play rob
in the sequel to the martian oh my god
they're going to be they're going to be
there i'm friends with andy weir i'll
put him on top of this podcast so i
think for analisa we should do sandra
bullock
oh who's going to play them the
characters yes
yes
and for rob uh
how about because he's so passive
aggressive christopher walken
okay
deal done we we've got so that's all
done so call in the end yeah yeah thank
you for that
is he so what if what if you're going to
a place like venus where it's 800
degrees is this at all none of this is
feasible no that's the end of well
there's an end of story right right end
of story well you can grow eggplant then
you put some cheese on and you instantly
have eggplant parmesan i guess what
that's about
very instantly yes yeah
just
for context a pizza oven is 500 degrees
and the surface of venus is 900 degrees
so
and i did the calculation you could cook
a pizza in seven seconds on the
windowsill and then some i got out
geeked and someone said no you left out
the radiative energy from the atmosphere
itself so it'll cook in three seconds so
yeah so i so no
our the steam guests today are not
thinking about plants on venus but mars
right is this is this is all building to
mars right hopefully why not this could
be used this could be used in mars
absolutely yeah yeah and also foods food
scarce areas on earth as well as another
is it yeah i want to just end on the
thought can either each of you just
briefly comment um
surely we're going to learn things from
your work
that will help us produce
food here on earth
in places that either previously were
not arable or
were are arable but now we can improve
on what their their uh yield is or
productivity or nutrition surely there's
some overlap here is that not right
oh absolutely one of the things that
this work does is it probes the edges of
the adaptability of plants here it is
various difficult spots it happens to be
an extraterrestrially difficult spot but
the analogy is the same
yeah there you go and a mars is drier
than the sahara so if you grow something
on mars we can do it in the center
we got to end it there this has been fun
and illuminating and
uh i i think you know when you guys have
uh when you can grow a
uh
what an apple tree give me a call we'll
bring you back on internet
talk
i apologize think of i think of isaac
newton and apple trees but uh you know
fruit and other things more interesting
than kale are would be a must otherwise
i'm staying here on earth just with you
or you know the krispy kreme donut i'm
going to go back to that if you really
are good at what you do you would figure
that out i'm just going to enjoy it
yeah you can you can live for centuries
off of krispy kreme doughnuts
the energy content is you can power
missiles
it's like a twinkie you know
thousand-year half-life
and when you guys walk to do you know
that when you do the celebrity walk for
the premiere of martian ii i we would i
would like to be with the two of you as
you know because they're going to be
have stars playing you in the movie so
i'd love to be there for that
awesome
all right annalisa paul and rob furl
delight to have you for the first time
on star talk and maybe it won't be the
last i and paul this will be your last
time
what
no you were brilliant here paul you
would like all in i'd love you man
neil degrasse tyson here you're a
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
[Music]